Now it's like beauty week here on the show.
And I was curious when you feel the most beautiful?
I think I feel the most beautiful when I have
like a bare face.
Even in my sweat pants.
Just like hanging out with my friends.
I don't know.
That's when I feel like the most like myself
and just clean and comfy.
Okay, so I have grown up with a camera in my face.
So I started at 11 months old in diapers
and I don't think I know a life without a camera.
A camera for me is safe.
It feels like a twin for me.
I loved, in the documentary,
when you went on camera
and you talked about the breakup with your fiance
and then you came back to it,
hours later, bare faced and crying.
What is your relationship with the camera?
I could never see another camera in my life and be okay.
Like my twin is my voice.
That's my twin.
And I, for me, all I need is a room with good acoustics
or a microphone and a stage and that's my twin.
For me, the camera has always just kind of showed up
in my life.
You know, acting was something that I started doing to pay
for my music lessons because my family couldn't afford those
without my acting gigs.
And so it was just kind of this
like way to always put money back into my music.
And yeah, I think for me, all I need is a microphone
and that's what makes me feel complete.
It's true.
It's you and it's your songs.
And I must say that one of the things that I applaud you
for most is not only putting your truths out there
whether it's a documentary or, you know,
speaking openly to people
but it's the way you put yourself into your music.
It's like each and every song is a page
from your most beautiful and personal book.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Wow, thank you.
All of my projects, like all
of my songs are my babies, right?
But like this album in particular, I like to say
that this one's like my teenager
because I've gone through so much
since the beginning of this, of making this album in 2018
that I've now watched it turn into a teenager
and that's because I spent so much time on it.
And thank you, that means a lot.
I marvel at your ability to work
through your life in your lyrics.
They are so compelling.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much, wow.
It's so true.
Okay, as a last question, is there anything,
without revealing anything that doesn't feel right to you,
is there anything that people don't already know about you?
Hm, I am a blue belt in jujitsu.
What?
Yeah, yeah.
It's a random fact that I like to throw at people.
I worked really hard to get it and I'm still
gonna once, once, you know, everything's good, COVID free,
I'm gonna pick up training again,
but I love jujitsu, yeah. (laughing)
Oh my God, that's so cool.
I'm so glad I asked.
Yeah, me too.
(laughing)
I think you are so fierce.
I think you are so incredible.
Thank you.
I just, I was so excited to talk to you,
there's just.
Mm, thank you.
You can see her documentary
"Demi Lovato Dancing With the Devil"
which is also her extremely personal album.
It is phenomenal word for word.
The documentary is on YouTube
and the powerful album "Dancing With the Devil,
"The Art of Starting Over" is the companion piece
which is also available now.
Thank you, Demi, so, so, so much.
Thank you for having me.
(upbeat music)